give me your hand
it's quite cool
and then just go back to your eyelines
again
[Music]
when lord of the rings hit theaters
it became a cultural phenomenon it still
hasn't really sunk in it's very strange
before lord of the rings rings of power
hits our screens
[Music]
we're opening up the et vault to get
behind behind-the-scenes stories i had
one particularly grievous injury from
the cast and crew of lord of the rings
after switching studios and going
through a few false starts in 1997
director peter jackson finally began
pre-production on this epic first of its
kind production and et was there with
the cast and crew every step of the way
as the trilogy made history
for so long this book has been described
as being unfilmable it's sort of the
great unfilmable novel it's film magic
at its very best this uh these books
were written
50 years ago and many people have tried
to turn them into films but it has not
been possible until now until the
technology existed
not just for that sort of magic but for
the fabulous scenery and and
locations which bring tolkien's
imagination to life
and to do that it was clear that jackson
and his team needed to create a film on
a scale that had never been seen we took
a different approach because we wanted
our film to have a feeling of reality so
we we took over this farm a year before
filming started and for a year
we planted gardens we put carrots in the
ground we put seeds of carrots in the
ground so they sprouted we planted
hedges we made roads we lit the rains
erode away the dirt and so that by the
time we actually had our film crew there
it felt like a real place it felt real
and the cabbages and the gardens of the
hobbit gardens were real cabbages for
peter finding an actor to play frodo was
key
frodo's a very
interesting character but a difficult
character because i regard him he's what
i call the everyman character you're
sort of seeing it through frodo's eyes
and frodo's you he's experiencing it the
story as you would experience it i
really wanted to be a part of it i was
so passionate about it that i wanted to
give everything you know to get this
role so i went to western costume in los
angeles and got a him to be a hobbit and
and we went into the hollywood hills and
and shot a few scenes edited it all
together i looked this tape and i saw
immediately that we found frodo i mean
just looking one look at elijah elijah
has the most incredible eyes i've ever
seen of any actor his eyes go right
through to his soul
by 1999 the cast and crew had moved to
new zealand for 18 months and began
immersing themselves in tolkien's world
the first thing that i did when i
arrived in new zealand was had a bow put
in my hand and you know arrows and just
learned to to do that and horse riding i
would train with bob anderson to get
these twin blades and some of his stunt
team so when he's not using his bow
which is his signature to his signature
weapon um legolas he's he's in in close
combat he has these two white knives
which i basically had to learn to use in
a very effective way for the camera you
know it was great to do that stitched
into the costume of gandalf was a pocket
in which i kept uh tolkien's book lord
of the rings and i consulted it daily
there was a wig there was a moustache
and there was a bin i think there was a
nose somewhere in the middle of all that
and then underneath that there was me uh
but i i'm glad that peter allowed me to
come through all that makeup i had one
particularly grievous injury uh when i
when i was running into an alpine lake
and some branch or debris or something
went through and punctured the foot and
i got a helicopter ride out of the deal
on some stitches and it was yeah it was
all very fun i could tell it was kind of
a serious injury because of the look of
the faces of the other people around you
know i kind of wasn't looking at it i
was sitting down and people were sort of
oh god it was pulling me closer there
was this
great thing i know elijah poked it with
a stick and peter jackson was like don't
touch his blood it's a lot of blood mike
will get a yeah
that's a lot of blood wait i got to be
able to see the camera i got to see the
camera don't lock the close-up during
the trauma dom
gets a splendor
like tiny splinter and almost faint
these days we're used to seeing cg
characters sharing screen time with real
actors but 20 years ago andy circus's
performance as gollum and the two towers
was revolutionary
we did a lot of work on like creating
like the individual pores of his skin
and saliva on his lips and his hair and
his eyes and his skin to feel like there
was blood under his skin that was
translucent it
you know that a lot of work went into
that which is a lot of it involving new
software that we created to give him a
very realistic look but of course you
know we've all seen the most beautiful
looking actor who can't act their way
out of a paper bag so once you create a
great looking golem you've still got to
somehow make this thing act we wanted
an actor in this case andy circus to be
in charge of gollum so andy
was on set filming with elijah wood sean
aston every time they did their scenes
with gollum we would be filming andy
andy would be reacting to them
delivering dialogue
talking you know making all the
decisions an actor had to make and then
later we would paint andy out and we
would put the gollum computer character
right over the top of andy we would do
rehearsals with andy and we did a couple
reference passes with him for every
scene and that way you know sean and i
would get comfortable with how we would
work with gollum
so when andy would leave the scene leave
the set and be off camera just for for
the dialogue
sean and i were comfortable with how he
moved and knew where he was meant to be
fighting with andy um and then he'd
leave and then sean and i would fight
with nothing remembering how we'd moved
and where he was
and you know we kind of choreographed it
all with andy and then he would step off
overseeing everything and then would
step in and kind of say well you know
and make comments about how he wanted to
be done we'd all talk about it but it
literally came down to sean and i
fighting with air
from fighting air to fighting the battle
of helm's deep the movie's big finish
took over three months to shoot and
viggo mortensen led the charge on and
off screen with the shooting vigo worked
incredibly hard i mean he was a real
hero to the film crew as well as just to
the movie i mean he
he was constantly inspirational
during the long nights of shooting um
and he he never got tired he um he
suffered a bit of injury he broke a
tooth
um during one of the helm's deep fights
a sword whacked him in the mouth and his
tooth
snapped off right at the root his front
tooth and fell on the floor with a clang
and
he grabbed it and he just said get me
some super glue i want to glue it back
in and we'll just carry on shooting try
me some super glue and of course we
stuck him in the car and we rushed him
down to the dentist so he could have
emergency work done but you know that
was like the spirit of vigo
the return of the king is the climax of
the trilogy and wrapping up this journey
through middle earth was a filmmaking
feat
i mean the most exciting part of it was
we're working with the horses we had um
some days where we were shooting with
250 horses which in itself is a fairly
spectacular amount of horses if you're
just standing there kind of seeing them
and smelling them
there's a lot of horses
and um and i had a lot of fun doing that
i did that was the day i really did feel
like the general in charge of an army
and but what we ended up doing you see
it was we looked at our shots with our
250 horses and we thought oh you know
what let's put another thousand horses
in the background um with with the
computers which ultimately gives the
film a great look because you just see
you know more horses than you could ever
imagine
it really was me running along with with
the gundorian soldiers at palmell
like um very very fast and and
uncomfortable uh close in the heat and
that really was the the the dust coming
up into our faces over and over again
that that really was me on shadow facts
galloping away and trotting into battle
that really was me wielding the staff
and the sword but as often as it was me
it was not me
and if ever you couldn't see my face
it was an actor pretending to be me just
as i'm pretending to be gandalf but
there were a lot of gandalfs
all with their different expertise
and my mind is to act
not to fight
but it wasn't just the cast and stump
performers having fun vigo mortensen's
son also got in on the action where he
played orcs i fought him in this last
movie in the battle of eleanor fields
luckily the choreography called for me
to evade his
his blow he also played a gondorian uh
soldier you know one of my
guys in the battle of the black gate you
know when i'm
being attacked by that giant troll
towards the end of that fight he's in
the background they're fighting
another cameo shawn aston's daughter
alexandra has a cameo at the end of the
film she plays
sam's daughter eleanor so she has her
own little moment at the end of the uh
the movie and she's she's wonderful
that's a family event yeah yeah she's
been a part of these movies for the five
years we've all been sort of
doing them and it's it's her
she gets a little piece of ownership
of the first i mean three of her seven
birthdays have been in new zealand when
when we watch this movie the faces of
all the extras are the faces of our
families
the faces of of their crew and their
families i mean it really would the
passing of time it'll mean more and more
in that sense because i i know those
people
20 years later and the love is still
there and now we're getting a new entry
in the lord of the rings canon lord of
the rings the rings of power premiering
september 2nd on prime video et's matt
cohen caught up with the cast and found
out everything you need to know about
this new story and some familiar faces
along for the ride i want to know where
your character fits into the saga tell
me anything you're allowed to tease me
sure i'm uh king of the elves yes you
are
each of us
must decide who we shall be
he was one of the elves that chose to
stay and protect middle earth and that's
his job and as we know in tolkien evil
is always right around the corner so he
certainly has his hands full i play a
human from the southlands i'm a healer
i'm a mother of a somewhat rebellious
teenage son but i'm also in a forbidden
romance with an elf so it's sort of like
the love story of the season we find him
in the southlands
so he is watching over the people
they've colonized that area and that
that's where the tricky part happens in
terms of his love for a
you just hear
the moment we feared
kate blanchett previously portraying do
you talk to the actress do you reach out
i don't talk to kate blanchett but i
think about her all the time
i think she might
honestly like those films and who and
adwin i was just so obsessed with so it
still
feels very surreal well my character is
kenneth brimbour who ultimately forges
the rings of power
but we're not there yet he's trying to
build a kind of heaven on earth for the
for the elves to because they're in a
sad place the elf at this point and uh
keller imbor is is trying to
build a city where they can all um try
and reclaim some of that lost valenor
that's about them your characters from
both the books and the films um with
hugo weaving previously portraying
it's a sort of right-hand man to the
king he's not a lord yet um he's very
interested in different peoples of
middle earth which we we get to see a
little bit of destroy it
there's definitely a weight of
expectation on my shoulders to to kind
of fulfill everyone's idea because they
have a sense of ownership over this
character he wants to on one hand
fulfill his father's dream
but also there's like this deep yearning
for something else a soldier's sister
she's the baby of the family uh she's an
aspiring architect on the cusp of
womanhood
a little insecure
smarter than she realizes you play a
character created for the series so does
that take pressure off or is that
additional pressure i think it's a
different kind of pressure i think
there's some really interesting things
in the character he's built on the
foundations of tolkien's work we meet
him floating on a raft in the middle of
the sundering seas
he's leaving behind something in his
past and he's moving forward towards
something else
my character's name is largo he's the
father of nori
he's a hard-foot prehistoric hobbit
um
what an amazing thing to say i can't
even believe i'm saying it my character
nori brownie foot she's a really
resolute inquisitive curious half her
she's a troublemaker
um but she just wants to improve the
harford's quality of life and does so by
by
taking risks she is there with nori and
her love for nori and poppy's the kind
of one who likes to draw her back in i
feel like the sons of powerful people
and i think his dad's frustration is
that um he's not bringing many new ideas
to the table because the current ideas
are suiting him pretty well i'm playing
a human that's like you know a new
character so i get to you know sort of
make up my own storyline for my
character so i play the character of
princess diesel she is the first
female dwarf that we will ever see on
screen
woo woo
she is the first um
dwarf of color to be able to host this
moment and make this huge franchise
accessible for all the generations
across the screen
is an iconic moment for me and and
hopefully for the world to draw in the
new fans and know that it is possible
dorian he's the prince so he's kind of
in line to the throne in in kaza doom
and we meet them at a very um
fruitful
life i suppose you saw it at the end of
the trailer there might be a big thing
there somewhere
there could be no trust between hammer
and rock
eventually one or the other
must silly big
[Music]